so I go to a gym with a lot of older
people and if I've learned anything it's
that old people really don't give a fuck
anymore but anyway I was with my trainer
when a random lady came up to us and
said um spin class is starting soon over
there in that room but you guys here are
in the way this is in the way so you
should consider going away times like
these make me wish that I could rewind
because right when I got home I thought
of like a million comebacks should I
take off my heads would have been great
or oh oh my god what does it feel like
what to have the entire universe revolve
around you or maybe I should have
reacted the way I always say I'm going
to oh I'm so sorry
I'm kidding I'd much rather be classy
about it I'm so sorry I mean your way oh
my god my apologies we totally didn't
mean but maybe I don't know and it's a
good thing that I didn't think of a
comeback cuz I could have said the
wittiest thing in the world and she may
have responded with you and I fuck with
me
alright take
look at that yeah that's a real
possibility I'll see you next week
stay off and Gotham or else I'll send a
senior citizen stripper to your house
and yes I do have a trainer so I can
safely do things like this
[Applause]